pachinko is being called one of the best
new shows of the year this epic tv saga
follows four generations of a korean
immigrant family the series travels
between korea japan and america telling
their multi-generational story of
sacrifice oppression and resilience
showrunner and executive producer and
writer sue hugh based the series on a
new york times best-selling novel of the
same name and the story is told through
sanja who grew up in korea in the early
20th century under japanese rule in this
clip sanja played by menha kim catches
the eye of han soo who's a powerful fish
broker he's played by south korean
superstar lee min ho
chubby choice
[Music]
[Music]
um
i think there's love in the air first on
cbs morning's filmmaker filmmaker rather
sue hugh joins us
i wasn't set at the table but really in
the living room the living room
i'm going to move in
it is so nice to meet you i was up late
watching i was just going to watch half
of it just to get an idea and before i
knew it it was one o'clock in the
morning it was three episodes yes yes
it's so good but listen to this review
for you miss sushu is it too soon to
crown this the best show of 2022.
what do you think when you hear that
it's gotta feel really good considering
how hard it took for you to get this on
the screen i think that's what it is i
would i would i wish i can say the
reviews didn't matter but
for this show because of how long it
took it took us four years to make this
and so many people just really gave us
their blood sweat and tears
to read reviews of people who not only
just accepted and embraced the show but
who got the show a show this is a
difficult show to get yes it's it means
a lot well there's a lot going on sue
because it's told in korean japanese and
english i've never seen that before
there are and it jumps from multiple uh
time periods but at the heart of it it's
a forbidden love story and it's about
the story of this little girl sanja who
i just immediately fell in love with you
say this is a relatable story even to
people who are not of korean descent why
absolutely
so many people have come up to me
through the making of this show for the
four years
people from all backgrounds all ages and
they talk about i just want you to know
this reminds me of my grandmother she
came over from germany she came over
from ghana she came over and then you
just realize everyone has a sunja in
their lives all of us
um and that's what this show has done
it's really started that conversation
with so many people so many tears yes
yes lots of tier and really tugs at the
heartstrings also it's so celebratory
too yes i want people you drew me in
with the open of the show your decision
the decision that you made to have such
a celebratory open because i to be
honest i didn't even know what pachinko
was i didn't know if it was a person i
didn't know if it was a place you knew
huh yeah well i mean i spent some time
in japan um in korea but but also i read
the book my wife and i read the book by
minjin lee and so but but tell everyone
what what did you know what pachinko is
no no i had no idea so pachinko is this
arcade-like game it's like a pinball
machine straight up and it's a game of
chance balls go flying in the air and
you either win or lose you have no
control over it and it's a great
metaphor for the show as well right
and you say the show is it's it's a
universal story about humanity now when
we read the book we thought to ourselves
this has got to be turned into a movie
or a series i'm a huge fan of
yeah it's a wonderful book you've made
some changes but the universal theme of
that humanity is inherent throughout the
entirety of it good
i mean because the book was this
staggering achievement in thinking about
the adaptation to screen the question
was how do we tell this story
in the cinematic form which is so
different from the novel form and the
thing i was most interested was that
conversation between generations because
it's my story yeah my parents came to
this country i was an immigrant it's a
it's the story that i really latched on
to because it was the most personal you
said when you grew up you didn't have
access to filmmaking so tell us a little
bit about a thousand miles yeah
yeah it's your program yeah or aspiring
writers and i give ucp and universal so
much credit for really putting their
mouth and their checkbook where you know
in terms for this program but growing up
in towson maryland and wanting to be a
filmmaker i always say
hollywood felt like going to the moon it
might as well be the moon right yeah and
i just don't want that
sense of struggle to i would love it if
people had a better opening your program
is called a thousand miles and it's
based on this chinese proverb that the
road to a thousand miles starts with one
single step and i just i love that idea
can i just say you look pretty good
sitting on top of the moon
one final review pachinko is a triumph
of visual storytelling that goes in its
own direction and finds a destination
that leaves you absolutely floored and
how masterfully it executes its vision
so bravo bravo
thank you so much for joining us thank
you for having me we appreciate you you
can watch pachinko starting today on
apple tv plus